i can't help but when you say you know
you've been
you know doing stuff with with kevin for
for so long
and uh you know i remember you and i the
uh linking up on twitter we were gonna
meet up we were gonna do some stuff like
uh
and um
it i i don't know what that at what what
was going on at that time but clearly
there was some some periods in your
relationship with kevin where he had to
just back off he's like yeah yeah like
you're you're not okay right now yeah
like what what uh
that's good just gotta be tough man
did did him
having to
sort of you know put a boundary in place
and back off and say yo you need to get
well
like did was there uh like a financial
consequence to that um yeah i mean well
i think
you know it made sense to me always i
mean there was always he never
for him and i it's like so yeah there
was for one it was like hey i need you
to sort of get better or you can't be
around the house
and you can't do the next movie like i
was supposed to be in jersey girl but i
couldn't be in it but it wasn't so much
like kevin was like
i'm not putting you in a hundred percent
because uh you're you're getting messed
up and you're in a bad place it was more
like hey you have a warrant out for your
arrest and we're filming we're filming
in uh philadelphia or pittsburgh
wherever they filmed it and you could
get arrested and then it'll like well to
shut the movie down you know i mean
right right um you will lose days so
there was like that so so that happened
a few times but not not that i didn't
get in the movie because in the past he
would always try to help me like hey if
this is you don't want to miss out on
this opportunity then you need to either
go into rehab or you're going to come
stay with me and you're going to get off
and you're going to stick by my side
like the right before jan saw bob
strikes back i i went and stayed with
him in his guest house and i literally
couldn't leave his house or leave the
guest house unless i was with him
and if he was going somewhere else i had
to go with him he wouldn't leave me
alone but it was a good it was a sweet
thing right he's boxing yeah because
he's like oh dude yeah we he got
he got to see it up close i remember it
was during christmas
and i had to go christmas shopping with
them and we were in the mall and you
know you just you're detoxing from
opiates you feel like you're carrying a
bag of bricks and you're just like your
nose is running i remember just sitting
down on every bench throughout the mall
while he was in there looking for
presents and i'm like
like an hour seemed like at six hours
you know and i remember just be like i
want to go and he'd like dude no you got
to wait another like we're going to get
through this and i didn't it was it was
horrible but in the end it was worth it
because then i got to do reboot and i
mean strikes back and it was great but
uh you know for me
it also like i never
resented him or was upset with him about
it because it the biggest thing was his
kid at the time all these times his
kid's now 20 uh 20 damn like my old she
is not 23. but at the time she was like
you know 10
12 uh you know eight years old i've ever
all the different years she was but it
was always like hey i don't want she's
getting older now she sees you she looks
up to you your uncle jay and if you come
to the house we used to be able to tell
her oh he's not feeling good he's got a
cold he's sick he's not but she she's
gonna get it now and i don't want her to
see like that and i didn't want her to
see me like that so you know i would
stay away and try to get better but for
the most part he always was involved
with trying to help either he stuck me
in rehab drove me there paid for it or
you know again that time uh you know i
didn't go i went to a detox but then
after i got out i got out in like a week
and then i stayed at his house i was
still withdrawing because it was off of
uh oxy's which you know isn't a week
it's like a month
um getting off of that feeling
physically uh okay with that but uh
yeah you know it's it's been
he's always stuck by even when he put
boundaries up it's not like he ever just
cut me off again we got to a point one
point where he he got close but it more
was like hey you're in really really bad
shape the kids old enough to like
see you
um and i just need you to make a
decision like go get go get better or i
just can't have you around like it
breaks my heart and he would like cry
and stuff you know it was never like a
mean thing like for sure scumbag get out
of here it was like you're breaking my
heart and he would cry and you know i
don't want you around the kid and and
yeah there's a there was a time i
remember i went to his house it was
thanksgiving and i always used to have
thanksgiving with them
and i remember me and him sitting out in
front of his house um and him crying and
being like i want to let you in but the
whole family's here and i had like a
tank top on and i had track marks and
you know he's like i can't have you see
him like that is and he's like i'm like
i can't come in for a plate of
thanksgiving dinner and he's like you
can't he's like here i'm gonna bring you
some food but i don't want the kid to
see you that way and it made sense to me
but it was like that was that was the
first time i actually got sober for like
a while i had stayed sober for like four
years
um and then i got kidney stones and then
they gave me demerol i was like i don't
want anything i don't want anything i'm
sober i'm in the program and they're
like yeah but if you want to pass the
kidney stone you got to take it and they
gave me that shot man and it was like
brought back that that beast and i was
like oh i forgot about this this is
great you know i mean the next thing you
know it was like oh i could handle it
and they gave me
pills to go home with and you know i was
counting every four hours and anyway so
then i relapsed for two years and now i
have uh 11 years wow dude brad man was
the rock bottom for you nodding off and
hitting the cop car
i read that in an article did you pass
out at a
stoplight and run into a cop you didn't
do that i didn't do that thank goodness
i honestly i lucked out man i i i never
i got arrested once i don't say i looked
out i got arrested once
um in jersey 1999 i i was driving with a
deployed air bag
apparently you can't do that so i
crashed and we crashed into a regular
car and we exchanged information and
then we went and copped our dope and
then on the way home and this girl i was
dating on the way home we had the car
was all smashed and the airbag we just
pushed back in so it was it wasn't like
full but it was like it was hanging out
like it was there so we're like driving
back and we got pulled over then for
that and i had i had a couple bags on me
and i'm like i should eat them i should
eat them and like get rid of it and i'll
be fine but i'm like there's no way
they're gonna search me there's no way
they're gonna search me just for no
reason and they searched me i got
arrested and i got uh
ror and then i got uh probation and
stuff luckily but that was the only time
in all the many oh all the years of
getting uh using and stuff like there
was times i lucked out where like cops
like stopped and was like hey come here
and i like ran and got away but i had
like bags on me and syringes and crack
pipes wow dude like i'm telling you this
one
fast when you got all that [ __ ] on you
yeah i'm gonna tell you this is like
i tell this story because it's it
i really do think about it all the time
because i had a warrant in new jersey
um and
and i was in la and i had all this stuff
on me and there was this there was like
a office building an empty lot and
another office building and there was a
fence and a fence to like this back
street and it was la brea and i was
walking and the cop pulls over and he's
like hello hey hey
and i turn around i see him and i go
what am i going to do so i hop the fence
and i start to run to the other side of
the road and all that cop had to do is
stand at that fence and let his partner
drive to the other side and cut me off
but the guy
jumped in the car and went with them and
i heard him get in the car and screech
off so because they were going to the
other side so i turned around went back
the way i came so my point is is that
one decision that cop made like if the
cops stayed there i would have been
arrested and i and it would have been
like my third second time getting
arrested from the 99 and
i'm just saying that would have
literally changed my life and and
luckily the cop decided to get back in
the car and drive around and i got away
that time but i don't know there was a
few times i got lucky like that man and
and uh
yeah i don't know i mean luckily i i
all the trouble i i had i had kevin's
support and and i know that was a big
made a big difference in in the outcome
of of everything because
i always had looked forward to like i'd
get sober because i wanted to do the
next movie and i was like you can't do
right yeah you can't do motivation yeah
but motivation can't be
like financial or for
power property and prestige we call it
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude